I landed a paralegal position at a law
firm when I started he tucked the whole
staff out to lunch and he was knocking
back quite a few cocktails he made some
comment about how he only hired the most
attractive woman and then he put his
hand on my thigh and said you are so
smart you are a breath of fresh air I
can't believe I have you on my team I
continue to come to work he would make
really inappropriate comments he said I
was a hot bitch and he said he made the
best decision hiring someone as
attractive as me because I'm going to
help him bring in more clients once I
hopped him was setting up his server and
he was so excited that he grabbed my
hips and then pinched my butt and then I
think he even said I love you made me
feel really uncomfortable and I just
said look this person doesn't understand
boundaries i sent him a resignation
letter he didn't take it very seriously
he even invited me out to louisiana for
his Easter family trip at this point I'm
just taking the avoid avoid avoid
approach but it doesn't seem to be
working and I'm not quite sure what to
do there was nothing out of the ordinary
about this review he got a
middle-of-the-road rating and I you know
I told him one night after an event I
was sitting with my employer and with a
host of the event who was a long time
major donor